GOOD MORNING WE'D LIKE TO-
CALLED ORDER THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY VIDEO
APPROPRIATIONS- WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST START- WITH THE- WE
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A QUORUM. AND
SO WILL CALL ON THE SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. HOLDEN THERE
BIGELOW PRESENT. BRIAN CALDERON
. CARIA DALAI. DAVIES MIKE FONG
. VINCE FONG. GABRIELLE. EDUARDO
GARCIA. LEVINE QUOQUE. HERE THIS
AREA. WEBER. I WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING
AS PART OF OUR REGULAR ORDER-
THE HEARING BEFORE WE BEGAN- I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO
COVER A FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN
REPLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS TODAY WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT A PRO DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT I MAY BE READ INTO THE
RECORD. OR REPRINTED. ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE. W. W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV
BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENT. THE
HEARING WILL THE HEARING ROOM
WILL BE OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE FOR
THIS HEARING. THE PUBLIC MAY
ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
BY PHONE BY CALLING AREA CODE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN WITH A
CONFIRMATION CODE. ONE EIGHT
FIVE DASH ZERO ONE DASH ONE ZERO
ZERO. THAT NUMBER IS ALSO LISTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. WE WILL ALSO ACCEPT
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY BILL
PLACED ON THE SUSPENSE FILE BY
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AND FOR
WHICH THE AUTHOR WAVE
PRESENTATION BEFORE THE CLOSE OF
THE REGULAR ORDER HEARING.
TESTIMONY ON THESE BILLS WILL BE
LIMITED TO A STATEMENT OF NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALLOW NO MORE THAN TWENTY
MINUTES TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
A GIVEN BILL IN NO MORE THAN
TWENTY MINUTES IN OPPOSITION.
PREFERENCE WILL BE GIVEN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO WE CAN HAVE EFFECTIVE
DELIBERATION. AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH THE COVERT
PANDEMIC WE HAVE LIMITED SPACE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO
WE CAN ENSURE EVERYONE MAINTAINS
SIX FEET OF SOCIAL DISTANCE.
WHICH DOESN'T SEEM LIKELY TO BE
A PROBLEM IN THIS ROOM. WE ALSO
PROCEED WITH THEIR WITNESSES IN
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THE ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE
WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT. AND FAIR HEARING. WE
APPLY THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS. IN ADDITION THIS
YEAR WE WILL AGAIN COMPLY WITH
ALL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS ARISING
OUT OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMIT LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS. DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE
EVEN VEILED THREATS. AS YOU CAME
INTO THE HEARING ROOM TODAY THE
SERGEANTS DIRECTED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES. OF
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR. I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN
ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF AND
OBSERVE THOSE RULES. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY BE SUBJECT YOU TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. COM COMMENTERS WHO
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS MEETING BY MAKING THREATS.
INCLUDING VEILED THREATS OF
POTENTIAL VIOLENCE WILL BE RULED
OUT OF ORDER AND TREATED AS A
DISRUPTION. WITH THAT WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM- WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
NOW IF WE COULD TO TAKING UP.
THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A SECOND. A LET ME SEE
WHO MADE THE MOTION. VICE THE
VICE CHAIR MISTER BIGELOW
INDUCTOR QUIRK SECOND WILL CALL
THE ROLL CALL ON THE- THANK OUR. CONSENT CALENDAR IS AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR COMMITTEE
ON EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT A.
B. SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE DAVIES A.
B. SIXTEEN FORTY ONE MAIENSCHEIN
A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE MEDINA
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY THREE
PATTERSON EIGHT AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY TWO RODRIGUEZ AB IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT SEATTLE SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN SEVEN LAMONT.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE BRIAN. BRIAN I
CALDERON. CALDERON I COULD DEAL
CARILLO I MAKE A DOLLY. MEGAN
DOLLAR AYE DAVIES MIKE FONG. MY
PHONE I VINCE FONG. VINCE FONG I
GABRIEL EDUARDO GARCIA LEVINE
HOLCK. WELL I HOPE I NAZARIAN
WHETHER WEBER I. OKAY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED I
WILL NOW LIKE TO DISPENSE WITH
THE SUSPENSE FILE WITH YOU READ
THE ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE
SUSPENSE FOR PROJECT. AB SIXTEEN
OH ONE WEBER AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
WEBER AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE
BENNETT AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN.
BOERNER HORVATH AB EIGHTEEN OH
THREE JONES SAWYER AB SIXTY
NINETY EIGHT MAIENSCHEIN AB
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED MAIENSCHEIN AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AYE MATHIS. AB
SIXTY NO TO MCCARTY A. B.
SEVENTEEN OH ONE MEDINA. HEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'D ALL BUT
NOW WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THE
HEARING THE COMMENTS BY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON ANY BILLS NOT
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. A PLEASE BE SURE TO LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL'S THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON A BILL OF PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. NOW.
THREE NINE I WILL TURN TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE- OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO. HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT. TODAY ON THE-
SUSPENSE FILE OR THE CONSENT FOR
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON EITHER
OF THOSE TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR THAT WILL
CLOSE THE LINE AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR TODAY.